bonjour berio leur génération europe
nous sommes ici à la cité internationale
universitaire au collège franco
britannique
l'europe à l'étranger en quoi est elle
utile c'est de cela dont nous allons
parler avec les étudiants européens et
avec notre invité aujourd'hui c'est
l'écologiste et yannick jadot
bonjour à tous alors le fait de parler
rim de parler de la place de l'europe
dans le monde aujourd'hui est ce que
c'est un sens tout particulier quand on
pense qu'on est en 2014 et qu'on est
juste cent ans après le début de la
première guerre mondiale c'est le
centenaire jules bah ouais s'entend
après la grande boucherie qui a été la
première guerre mondiale ça a un sens de
parler de de l'union des peuples
européens je pense mais en revanche
c'est un sens d'en parler mais
actuellement l'union européenne
la question c'est est ce qu'elle est une
action en faveur de la paix excédera moi
je ne pense pas malgré les mecs bonne
déclarait les grandes déclarations etc
elle mène une politique de en faveur de
la guerre économique en fait finalement
entre les peuples parce que c'est ça le
libre échange c'est la guerre économique
entre les peuples et donc oui c'est un
sens à des dates en parler aujourd'hui
je ne suis pas du tout d'accord avec ces
petits jobs
je trouve que justement l'objet de
l'union européenne cédait de
développement économique
ensemble au sein de l'europe et je
trouve qu'à nous avons vraiment réussi à
faire ça je tue pas dans quel sens il ya
une guerre économique entre les
bénévoles c'est juste un exemple en 2012
contre l'union l'apn a reçu le prix est
un exemple du succès qu'on a qu'on a
atteint il n'y a pas un seul un seul
continent qui a réussi à attendre une
telle un tel objectif
on est un vrai continent pacifique c'est
intéressant tu dis que l'objectif de
paix menés par l'union européenne n'est
pas atteint parce qu'aujourd'hui on mène
encore une guerre qui est économique
c'est vrai mais au moins l'inquiétude
que nous on peut avoir aujourd'hui entre
20 et 25 ans c'est pas de finir dans une
tranchée avec un fusil à la main c'est
de finir au chômage
non mais c'est intéressant mais le
risque existe toujours
alors je voudrais que on aille voir un
petit peu les fondamentaux du sujet on a
parlé
de l'économique inaptes ou des sujets
qu'on aborde veut quand on parle de
l'europe forcément vrai qu'on regarde la
mécanique et les outils que possède
l'union européenne en matière de défense
de diplomatie on regarde c'est un sujet
de thierry scharff mise en image par
hugo nicolas et c'est l'essentiel
une chose est sûre les faiblesses de
l'union européenne sur la scène
internationale n'est pas en rapport avec
sa place de première puissance
économique mondiale
et pourtant l'europe s'est dotée depuis
le traité de lisbonne en 2009 d'une
politique européenne de sécurité et de
défense la psb avec deux innovations la
nomination d'un haut représentant aux
affaires étrangères et à la politique de
sécurité
une sorte de ministre des affaires
étrangères light c'est la britannique
catherine ashton qui occupe actuellement
le poste est le service européen pour
l'action extérieure dont le siège est à
bruxelles et qui détient un réseau de
130 9 délégations dans le monde
l'action extérieure de l'europe s'appuie
sur des valeurs communes telles que la
démocratie la paix et droits de l'homme
la coopération multilatérale ou le droit
international
en pratique les états membres réunis en
conseil à définir des positions communes
par exemple la non prolifération
nucléaire et met en oeuvre des actions
communes nomination de représentants
spéciaux programme de déminage est aussi
en voie de force militaire ou civil 27
opérations civiles ou militaires ont été
lancés sur trois continents déployons
vingt mille hommes 14 sont en cours
comment ma vie en afghanistan ou au
large des côtes somaliennes où l'europe
cette loi à lutter contre la piraterie
l'europe est aussi capable d'embargo ou
de sanctions économiques par exemple au
régime syrien ou biélorusse question
financement en 2013 l'action extérieure
européenne aura coûté 9,4 milliards
d'euros soit 6,4 pour cent du budget
total européen dérisoire si on le
compare au sol budget français de
défense de 31,4 milliards
il ya donc aujourd'hui 14 opérations
civilo militaire en cours comme au mali
en afghanistan est ce que quand il ya
des crises dans le monde james par
exemple tu as l'impression sur ces dix
dernières années que l'europe a joué son
rôle en matière de diplomatie ou de
défense je ne sais pas s'il ya un rôle
pro l'europe tant la défense l'action
est rangea pour moi est fini
selon toi l'action militaire dans le
monde pour moi c'est le cas de la
souveraineté des états et on ne peut pas
confier ce rôle à l'union européenne
pourquoi c'est pas le sort de l'union
européenne pour moi et pour les anglais
c'est un projet économique d'intégration
économique pourquoi faut-il l'étranger
c'est pas réaliste comme position de
vouloir garder au niveau de la
souveraineté des états ses compétences
là parce que bon c'est toujours on va
dire que c'est toujours le même argument
qui revient mais ce que représente la
population de l'union européenne au
niveau mondial c'est 5%
la population de l'union européenne pas
de la france si on prend le poids
économique dans dix ans il y aura plus
aucun état européen dans le top 10 des
économies une date
comment peut-on avoir une légitimité sur
le plan diplomatique
sur le plan de la défense si on a pas on
ne rassemble pas les force à un niveau
européen
et pourtant je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de sujets sur lesquels comme on l'a vu
dans le reportage les droits de l'homme
la démocratie même l'écologie ou l'union
européenne partagent des valeurs
communes qu'elle peut porter sur un plan
international
donc pour moi c'est une nécessité qu' il
ya un rassemblement des forces
européennes sur le la diplomatie on
touche au coeur justement de cette
question est ce qu'on arrive à avoir une
centralisation une europe qui peut
penser la diplomatie extérieure
ensemble on va faire tout de suite
rentré notre invité qui va nous éclairer
nous apporter son point de vue bonjour
yannick jadot
bonjour
je voulais le député européen écologiste
depuis 2009
vous êtes vice président de la
commission du commerce international et
coordinateur pour le groupe des verts
alors on voulait parler surtout
diplomatie et surtout par les défenses
et finalement on parle de la guerre qui
existent aujourd'hui qui est celle
économique forcément on est obligé de de
glisser sur ce terrain là quand on parle
du rapport de l'europe au reste du monde
je crois en tout cas c'est pas on peut
pas les dissocier parce que c'est vrai
que l'europe
globalement une position hégémonique sur
le monde pendant quatre siècles
et puis on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui la
globalisation à la changer qui a des
pays émergents qui viennent contester
notre hégémonie et on voit bien
d'ailleurs que de plus en plus dans nos
sociétés nous payons un certain coût de
la mondialisation
avant c'était simplement à notre profit
donc on s'enrichit c'est sur les
ressources naturelles du reste du monde
bon maintenant aujourd'hui on paie une
partie des coûts de la mondialisation et
que ça affole beaucoup nos sociétés et
nos opinions publiques donc et puis à
partir du moment où il ya eu la fin la
chute du mur de berlin la fin de
l'affrontement est ouest qui était un
affrontement essentiellement sur le sol
européen
eh ben on a eu l'impression que
finalement la diplomatie a laissé la
place à une mondialisation économique à
une mondialisation libérale qui s'est
substitué jir très largement à la
diplomation nature et la diplomatie
européenne
un positionnement aujourd'hui on lui
reproche par exemple ne pas avoir vu
arriver le printemps arabe est de ne pas
avoir eu un positionnement européen
quelle est votre lecture c'est vrai que
en tout cas elle est largement
insuffisante
elle est largement insuffisante à mon
avis pour deux raisons c'est pas facile
de se mettre d'accord à 28 par rapport à
la russie
on voit bien que la relation de la
pologne et des pays baltes à la russie
peut pas être la même que celle du
portugal ou de l'espagne
donc évidemment à se mettre d'accord et
donc à trouver un consensus et puis la
réalité c'est que c'est vrai que les
états au niveau des états nations ont
abandonné beaucoup de souveraineté aux
marchés et donc ils font vivre
médiatiquement il essaye de faire vivre
dans leur pays
l'idée que les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement
encore des grands chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qui décide de tout quelle
est la puissance aujourd'hui même d'un
pays comme la france face à la
spéculation financière internationale
est très faible
on voit bien que la france face à un
acteur comme monsieur mittal est très
faible face au climat on est très faible
face à la chine
on est très faible si on est isolé voyez
bien comment se construit la politique
c'est qu'on a une grande messe
présidentielle tous les cinq ans où on
nous explique que le président dans les
frontières de l'état nation va nous
sortir d'une crise
forcément mondialisé et donc plus les
états ont perdu de pouvoir et plus
finalement ils essayent de faire croire
que sur la scène internationale ils sont
puissants
l'un d'entre vous disais c'est vrai que
dans dix quinze ans il aura plus d'états
européens au sein du g8
c'est vrai qu'on voit notre difficulté à
peser sur les affaires du monde et donc
à la fois cette résistance à avoir une
politique commune de défense
une diplomatie commune ce qui est
parfois totalement aberrant à ce qu'il
faut avoir 25 27 ambassade en malaisie
puis on peut quand même sérieusement
s'interroger alors on va donner à
paroles alors n 1 belge trouve que vous
avez entièrement raison c'est notre seul
moyen en fait de faire un poids de nous
affirmer sur la chaîne internationale
surtout quand finalement nous les aurons
fait seul moyen quoi pas besoin de nous
unir de mutualiser nos moyens en terme
par exemple fort d'être très concrets
les ambassades
il ya certaines ambassades et jacky ont
été créés des franco allemande à
certains endroits donc c'est un premier
pas mais en plus on bénéficie d'un rôle
on a toujours été vu comme les
médiateurs enfin surtout depuis la
manière dont on a résolu la seconde
guerre mondiale dans certains continents
en asie et sont demandeurs de nos
conseils eux qui sont en proie à des ddd
violents conflits médiateur je trouve
que c'est une notion extrêmement
intéressante parce que c'est vrai que je
disais tout au départ
l'europe a été une puissance hégémonique
très forte
c'est la première puissance commerciale
du monde c'est surtout un un politique
et que typiquement non mais là la façon
dont par exemple la france et la
grande-bretagne s'accroche au poste au
conseil de sécurité
notre siège au conseil de sécurité il ne
m'est pas l'europe ne remplace pas la
france la grande-bretagne
europe pour changer notre mode de
régulation au conseil de sécurité
oui c'est ça montre glas notre frilosité
a passé une étape supérieure est ce que
c'est le sens qui s'imposent forcément à
ce que vous avez l'impression qu'à une
frilosité alors james toi tu penses que
c'est très bien comme ça l'union
européenne elle est économique et c'est
la base et ça suffit est-ce que vous
avez l'impression qu'il ya un besoin
finalement de pratiquer cette bascule
des pouvoirs oui bien sûr par exemple
vous parler de cette volonté de garder
le poste de sécurité à moi à mon avis ça
vient quand même de la peur de la peur
d'une chute de ceux de ce grand
organisme qui peut être l'union
européenne donc là c'est vraiment le
fait que les étangs en réalité cherche
quand même toujours à se défendre même
de dans l'union européenne pourquoi
parce que ces expressions de la crise
économique
mais peut-être que justement puisqu'on
revient toujours à la question
économique qu'elle est induite par tous
est ce que la crise économique n'a pas
aussi bousculer les mentalités qu'est ce
que t'en pense que oui dit-il fait que
du coup il ya des prises de conscience
ça fait pas très longtemps réalité qu'on
se pose la question la diplomatie
européenne à l'international ou de la
défense
tout ça a été mis en place sur les cinq
dix dernières années vraiment alors que
l'europe existe depuis 60 normalement
c'est que depuis 2009 mais à mon avis le
le débat d'une de la place de l'europe
dans le monde
il est beaucoup plus large que juste la
politique extérieure de l'europe
vous parliez de du droit de veto au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu je pense
que là c'est quelque chose on est sur un
point vraiment centrale parce que il
s'agit de savoir quelle architecture
politique on veut au 21e siècle c'est à
dire que on est la mondialisation nous a
fait prendre conscience qu'il ya un
certain nombre de problèmes qui peuvent
être résolus que à l'échelle
internationale et les problèmes de
l'environnement les problèmes de gestion
des ressources non renouvelables etc
et là dessus je pense que l'europe un
rôle qui fondamental à jouer parce que
il s'agit pas seulement de protéger des
intérêts des pays
il s'agit de d'exporter un modèle
d'affirmer des valeurs qui sont celles
d'une internationale comme
et on a tous des egos et ça en gros on
n'a pas tous des ego c'est que encore
une fois le jeu politique et médiatique
il se construit les chaînes nationales
donc un chef détails de gouvernement
doivent faire croire qu'il a beaucoup de
pouvoirs mais ça marche ça doit ça doit
changer ça doit absolument changer vous
savez les réunions du g8 et du g20
regardez tous ceux qui tous les chefs
d'état sortant nous disent ça en fait ça
sert à rien c'est une grande messe on se
voit on fait des photos le président
français s'affiche à côté du président
américain
tout ça donne l'impression du pouvoir
mais n'est pas la réalité du pouvoir
et quand on voit notre relation de
l'europe par rapport à la chine ou par
rapport à la russie
on voit bien que ces pays arrive
totalement à nous diviser la chine quand
elles se baladent en europe
quand le président chinois ou le
prémunit sua se baladent en europe
ils viennent pas dans les institutions
européennes il joue chaque état membre
les uns contre les autres
les russes font exactement la même chose
ils font du chantage des investissements
ici du chantage là ce qui fait qu'on
n'arrive pas à avoir de politique
commune vis-à-vis de ces pays là et donc
on arrive pas c'est manipuler sur la
question du dumping social sur la
question des droits de l'homme sur la
question du dumping environnemental du
dumping fiscal ou du dumping monétaire
on n'arrive pas à poser et ça c'est une
vraie difficulté est d'ailleurs regardez
ce qui représente l'europe du point de
vue diplomatique
lady ashton à la com été choisie parce
qu'elle ne fait donc pas personne donc
en permanence on met au niveau européen
et non pas des jacques delors on met au
niveau européen des gens qui vont pas
faire d'ombré
alors je vous propose maintenant
d'évoquer le fait que l'union européenne
mène une action humanitaire sans égal au
point qu'on dit d'ailleurs d'elle que
c'est la plus grande ong du monde
lorraine tu es allé enquêter là dessus
tu as été notre tin tin
notre reporter de 10 mois comment tu
vécu cette expérience
c'était très intéressant je savais que
l'union jouait déjà un rôle important en
terme de dead de développement et
humanitaire mais là on allait rencontrer
ces gens là je me suis rendu compte que
vraiment c'est est centrale dans le raid
pour le coup ça fait plaisir de faire
partie de l'union européenne
à l'écouter on va regarder le reportage
de lorraine guidé par thierry scharff
lauren 22 ans se verrait bien diplomate
un métier tout privé pour cet europhile
fervente né aux pays bas et qui a fait
ses études en partie en angleterre et
journalistes ça lui irait bien aussi
étrangers et pourtant il ya un domaine
dans lequel elle est hyper présente ces
humanitaires pourquoi enquête
et c'est parti pour la première
interview en duplex de bruxelles
attention bonjour tout le monde est prêt
et je suis prêt à 90
comment est-ce qu'on peut expliquer que
l'europe accorde autant d'importance à
l'aide humanitaire et surtout finançable
alors l'union européenne et
l'organisation dans le monde qui donne
le plus d'être développement en 2012
c'est plus de 50 milliards d'euros d'
s'est énormément d'argent que l'union
européenne a pu investir pour lutter
contre la pauvreté dans les pays et plus
les plus atteints par la pauvreté
extrême pour donner une source de
comparaison c'est deux fois plus que les
états unis pour la même année
mais alors qui a dit que les européens
n'avaient pas un sacré coeur
parmi les nombreuses ong qui bénéficient
des aides européennes
lo ng française agronomes et
vétérinaires sans frontières engagé dans
le programme agir sahel un programme de
développement destiné à venir en aide
aux populations de cette région
africaine touchée notamment par la
question des sécheresses aujourd'hui
dans le budget global d'agronomes et
vétérinaires sans frontières le
financement européen représente 40% du
budget dont vous voyez c'est un
financement essentiel c'est le premier
contributeur
donc finalement sans l'aide européenne
aucun de ces projets n'existerait donc
sans leur offre pas de projets mais
comment expliquer l'extrême générer ces
lignes européennes
j'ai rendez vous avec rony brauman qui
est pour moi la référence en la matière
la raison pour laquelle l'europe est
extrêmement engagée dans l'humanitaire
c'est parce qu'elle n'a pas de politique
étrangère commune c'est parce que les
désaccords entre les différentes nations
qui la composent sont telles qu'il n'y a
pas de synthèse possible mais on peut
tout de même se réjouir que poule aussi
important que l'europe apporte des
ressources à une action qui tout même
mérite d'être soutenue doit être
soutenue aussi bien par des particuliers
que par des entités politiques
la générosité comme lourd de
consommation plus humanitaire par défaut
pas seulement une dernière étude concon
qu'on a fait un par exemple montrer que
notre aide au développement dans les
sept prochaines années sera complètement
remboursé si je pars le nombre de
d'investissement de point de croissance
qu'elle ramène en afrique autant qu en
europe donc ce que je veux dire
on est là pour sauver les vies mais
c'est aussi dans notre intérêt en termes
par exemple de croissance économique a
finalement on n'est pas totalement
généreux purement généreux gilles ta
réaction
moi je vois là une contradiction majeure
qui est montré dans ce sujet là par
exemple on voit des initiatives des
projets qui sont développés au sahel etc
l'union européenne dunant et va donner
et de l'autre à reprendre en fait parce
que les accords économiques qui sont
passés qui empêche les pays africains de
subventionner leur agriculture par
exemple on dit que ce sont des échanges
n'ont alors que nous on subventionne
notre agriculture par le biais par le
biais de la politique agricole commune
et sinon une ong juste un autre exemple
est une autre contradiction qui me
semble vraiment c'est un quart est
édifiant c'est la palestine
l'union européenne donne régulièrement
des millions d'euros d'argent public
pour développer des infrastructures en
palestine notamment dans la bande de
gaza en 2009 si l'opération plomb durci
toutes les infrastructures construites
par l'union européenne ont été détruites
alors d'un côté on donne de l'autre côté
on prend jamais une seule sanction
contre l'état israélien
alors qui viole le droit international
constamment par le biais de la
colonisation etc et deuxième deuxième
chose juste on ne sanctionne pas on
pourrait avoir juste laisse-moi fine et
on pourra avoir une politique de
sanctions économiques contre les
entreprises européennes qui collabore à
la colonisation
moi j'en vois plusieurs choix orange
orange participe à la colonisation
d'eolia des audiences ne tient pas la
colonisation et bouygues bâtiment
participe à la colonisation on ne les
sanctionne pas et c'est le même cas pour
areva au niger par exemple aussi si je
peux me permettre
tout ce qui est dit là est vrai la
question c'est est ce qu'il ya un
endroit où se construit une telle
perversité non c'est à dire que moi j'ai
travaillé pour l'union européenne au
bangladesh
soutenez d'énormes projets des ong sur
la lutte contre la pauvreté notamment
pour les en faveur des femmes mais c'est
vrai qu'une bonne partie des relations
des états membres européens au
bangladesh ne remettait pas en cause la
corruption du gouvernement bangladais ce
que j'ai bien mais ça veut pas forcément
dire qu'à un moment on est simplement
cynique en dix ans là on va aider parce
que c'est sympa là on est cynique parce
qu'on les empêche de se développer et la
sensation de la cohérence et ça va vous
la question de la cohérence et des
valeurs mais ce que je veux dire c'est
que dans la même façon de
l'administration en france ou du point
de vue politique ou dans notre
fonctionnement parfois puis on est aussi
pétri de contradictions moi je me bats
au niveau de la commission du commerce
international sur tous les enjeux que
vous avez mentionné y compris faut
savoir quand même que l'union européenne
met en place aujourd'hui des
vérifications très stricte sur les
produits qui viennent des colonies pour
ce qui concerne la palestine
donc il ya des instruments mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya un rapport de force
politique qui est très compliquée à
mettre en oeuvre ce que je veux dire
c'est qu'il ya pas il n'ya pas le con
clos et il n'ya pas l'extrême générosité
l'union européenne n'atteint pas les
objectifs fixés par les nations unies en
matière d' aide donc elle n'est pas
généreuse
il ya du retour mais c'est le grand
bailleur c'est monde mais c'est le plus
grand bailleur et un certain nombre de
ces projets sont extrêmement pertinent
et je vous propose maintenant de
regarder la question de notre partenaire
technikart olivier malnuit on y répond
juste après la puissance douce cette
politique étrangère européenne basée sur
l'absence de conflits en fait et plus
sur un système de pressions amicales ou
une amicale
on est vraiment en droit de se demander
si au fond ça marche tant que ça puisque
on se rend compte que lorsqu'il ya
urgence lorsqu'il ya une crise à régler
seuls quelques états interviennent
souvent de façon isolée comme ça a été
le cas récemment de la france donc le ma
question c'est la soft power
est ce que c'est vraiment efficace c'est
vraiment efficace selon toi ce que c'est
là dessus finalement qu'il faut
s'engager
oui je trouve que c'est ça pourrait être
efficace dans les domaines où l'union
européenne devaient agir donc tout ce
qu'il s'agit de conclure des accords
économiques fabi sanctions économiques
c'est bien et je pense que faire d
action unifiée plus fortes comme
l'intervention militaire puisque c'est
pas dans le sort de l'union peine garder
le problème c'est que après la chute de
l'urss
le temps est elle toujours été là pour
défendre l'europe problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le temps qui est dirigée
par les états unis
il se barre en asie donc maintenant
c'est aux européens de reprendre leurs
responsabilités et on est tout seul
finalement donc il faut tirer vraiment
la sellette des larmes les européens
doivent malheureusement peut-être se
mettre à créer une politique de défense
commune
parce que sinon on va être complètement
tout seul et même si les anglais sont
pas d'accord il ya forcément des moyens
pour faire ça pour s'arranger sans eux
sans dec
à l'origine il tombait nationale qui
refuse la politique européenne de
défense c'est pas la grande bretagne à
l'origine dans les années soixante dix
c'est la france qui refuse d'appliquer
tous les français sont prêts à se placer
en leader grâce à la structure c'est ça
le problème c'est que la france est
toujours prête à faire quelque chose
c'est les leaders elle est toujours
prête à faire un pas vers l'europe si
l'europe ressemble à la france ça peut
pas fonctionner comme ça et les bulgares
alors jamais leader sans jamais leader
mais je pense qu'il ya un leader
européen et c'est clair que c'est
l'allemagne c'est un madame angela
merkel qui a tout cas vous le créez
cette idée d'une europe comme une petite
comme la petite suisse qui est la sorte
pas voir mais que c'est un modèle qui
c'est c'est évident que ça marche très
mal et que finalement l'europe se tourne
toujours vers les états unis
donc je pense pas qu'on est seul au sens
pour la défense au complet
si vous voulez l'histoire de l'allemagne
fait que la perspective de d'intervenir
de manière militaire dans le monde
reste un problème allemand à table mais
un tabou oui enfin ça reste extrêmement
compliqué mais va falloir et venir y
compris en matière d'efficacité on voit
qu'aujourd'hui l'europe
on a vu ce que ça donnait en libye on
n'arrive pas à projeter une intervention
militaire sans le soutien des états unis
c'est pas possible alors qu'on dépense
des centaines de milliards d'euros pour
les dépenses militaires en europe
mais comme on dépense chacun dans notre
coin on n'arrive pas à créer les
économies d'où la nécessité de
mutualiser la même façon on doit voir
autour de 1.52 million de soldats en
europe on a un pet 150000 qui sont
capables d'intervenir dans le monde
mais comme ça j'ai du jh est en réalité
le budget est très faible parce que
quand vous regardez jamais il ajouté oui
que je note c'est que si vous avez été
choisi mais c'est beaucoup mais on
n'arrive pas aujourd'hui trouver les
modalités
il faudrait un budget centralisée quand
on va quand même une très belle action
extérieure européenne aura coûté moins
de 10 milliards d'euros sans tiers de ce
qu'on fait parce qu'on n'a pas d'armée
parce qu'on n'a pas d'armée européenne
moi je crois que ça se tissent ça sans
visage ça se construit il faut se re
définir sans faux pas ou si on veut
avoir une politique étrangère européenne
forte
il faut un moment donné est en capacité
d'intervenir donc je crois qu'il faut
une armée mais la question de
l'intervention européenne doit se faire
notamment si gliese au mandat des
nations unies que peut-être le premier
corps qu'il faudrait créer c'est des
gens qui font de la prévention
d'intervention militaire son appel
d'intervention civile en fait quand on
parle de la centrafrique
on l'a vue venir quand même ça fait des
mois et des mois qu'on sait qu'on a
convergent à la catastrophe humanitaire
et si on est si on avait des vrais corps
européen de militaires européens qui
commencerait par intervenir pour les
missions des nations unies l'émission
paix des nations unies
ça serait pour nous progressivement
aller vers une forme de mutualisation et
d'une plus grande cohérence de nos
internationaux mange une question à ce
qu'il soit là en fait vu le manque de
démocratie actuellement dans l'union
européenne quand il s'agit de décider
des politiques économiques et c'est la
juste on va signer avec les états unis
par exemple un grand marché
transatlantique où les peuples ne seront
pas consulté qui décidera de ces
politiques là quand on a ramé européenne
est ce que c'est le parent je la connais
un qui va décider on sait
qu'actuellement ondes et les européens
ne peuvent pas décider
et là je me bats je me bats tous les
jours au sein la commission du commerce
à thein sein du parlement européen
justement pour je m'occupe de ce sujet
du traité transatlantique et pocket la
démocratie mais c'est propre c'est
absolument scandaleux on en train de
négocier des choix de société sur notre
alimentation sur nos services publics et
les citoyens sont exclus ils peuvent
même pas consulté les documents mais là
à la fois on a besoin d'europe
il faut dissocier je suis d'accord sur
le fait qu'aujourd'hui une bonne partie
des missions ne sont pas démocrates et
pascal sont prises par les gouvernements
ne nous trompons pas c'est pas parce que
la commission est une technocratie
insupportable elle est parfois mais
c'est parce que des gouvernement décide
si les citoyens européens ne veulent
plus de politiques d'austérité ou ne
veulent une diplomatie plus fort qu il
faut qu ils l'expriment dans les urnes
si vous avez des politiques néolibérales
en europe aujourd'hui c'est parce que
les citoyens européens ont
majoritairement voté pour des
gouvernements mais aux libéraux ou une
majorité au parlement européen qui est
plutôt libérale donc c'est aussi aux
citoyens à ne pas faire de l'europe une
sorte de fantasme d'idéologie
l'europe est un espace politique c'est
un espace politique si on s'en empare on
en fait ce qu'on veut si on le laisse
aux autres
et bien c'est les autres qui décident
ailleurs vous voulez en train dissidence
oui absolument
on arrive à la fin de cette émission
merci beaucoup je rappelle la sortie de
votre livre il ya quelques semaines aux
éditions plon
entrons en dissidence merci à chacun
d'entre vous on se retrouve le mois
prochain pour parler d'un nouveau thème
de génération europe et en l'occurrence
ce sera au tour des frontières de
l'europe
comment les dessine ton que sont les
limites au mois prochain a très vite
oui